So what do we have right here?
Well, this is just
a water molecule.
And this right over
here, let's see,
we have 1, 2, 3 carbons
in our backbone.
So this would be
meth, ethy, propane.
We all have single
bonds right here.
So this is propane.
Let me write that out.
This is-- give myself
some space-- propane.
And then on the
number 2 carbon, I
have both a methyl
group and a bromo group.
And bromo comes before
methyl in alphabetical order.
So I could write this as
2-bromo-2-methylpropane.
So that's this molecule that
we have right over here.
Now, what we're
going to imagine--
it's sitting in
some water, and I
have one water molecule
drawn right over here.
Let's imagine that we have
this bromine right over here.
It's pretty neutral.
It is neutral because it
has seven valence electrons.
Or you could say, it has
the charge equivalent.
It has 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
And then it has half
of this bond that's
composed of two
electrons, so that's
what's keeping this
neutral right over here.
But we do know that
bromine-- well,
it's not completely unstable
if it were to take an electron,
because that would get it
to eight valence electrons.
We know that it's more
electronegative than carbon,
which means that, if
it's sharing a bond,
it's more likely to take the
entire bond than carbon is.
So let's imagine a scenario.
Let's imagine a scenario
where bromine takes these two
carbons in this bond
right over here.
And this isn't going to be a
super-fast thing that happens,
because this molecule
right over here,
the 2 bromo-2 methylpropane,
is actually reasonably stable.
So I'm not saying this is going
to just happen automatically.
It's going to happen super-fast.
But it could happen.
And so to show that
this isn't going
to be only a one-way
reaction, I'll
show that it's in equilibrium.
So the equilibrium, I'll
draw two arrows like that.
And so once this
happens, the bromine
would turn into a bromide anion.
So let me draw it right over.
So the bromide anion-- so it's
going to have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
And then both electrons
from that shared bond,
it now has a negative 1 charge.
Now, if that happened, what
would happen to this left over,
to what's now going to be the
thing that the bromine was
connected to, I
guess you could say?
Well, let's draw that.
So we have this carbon,
our number 2 carbon.
We have the CH3
right over there.
And we go back to CH3.
And then I had this
blue methyl group.
So I had this blue
methyl group right here.
And the way I'm drawing, it
kind of pops out of the page.
My attempt to draw it popping
out of the page-- so this
is it popping out of the page.
And now, what's its
charge going to be?
Well, it just gave
up half of this bond,
the equivalent of an
electron's charge.
So it just gave
up-- you can kind of
think of it as giving
up an electron.
So this is going to
have a positive charge.
And a positive charged
carbon like this,
we would call this
a carbocation.
So this right over here is a
carbocation, positive charge.
And the reason why this is
not a crazy thing to happen
is that this is a
tertiary carbon, which
means it is connected to
three other carbons-- 1, 2, 3.
A tertiary carbon, one
way to think about it
is that this positive
charge can kind of
be shared with its
brothers a little bit more.
So a tertiary carbocation is
more stable than a secondary
and definitely more
stable than a primary.
Secondary would be if it was
only connected to two carbons.
But this is tertiary-- so
let me write this down.
This is a tertiary carbocation.
This carbon is connected
to three other carbons.
That's where the
tertiary comes from.
So once again, it can happen.
I'm not saying that
this reaction is just
going to go superfast
in that direction.
that's why we did these
equilibrium arrows.
Now, let's bring this
oxygen into play.
Sorry, not the oxygen, let's
bring this water into play.
So this water, as you can
imagine, the water is neutral.
It seems pretty
reasonable in the state.
But the oxygen end
of the water does
have a partial negative charge.
We've seen in the past that,
because oxygen is a lot more
electronegative
than hydrogen, you
have a partial negative side
on the side of the oxygens,
and you have a partial
positive charge,
on the side the hydrogens.
And so you have this
positive carbocation.
This has a partially
negative charge.
So you could imagine
that this molecule might
be attracted to this is nucleus.
Now, it's not going
to be super attracted
the way that a
hydroxide anion would.
A hydroxide anion has
a full negative charge.
This only just has a little
partial negative charge.
But it could still be attracted
to something very positive
like this.
So in this situation, the water
molecule is a weak nucleophile.
So this is a weak nucleophile,
not as strong as a hydroxide
anion that has a
full negative charge.
But if it sees something
positive like this
and it bumps in
the right way, you
can imagine that one of
these pairs of this oxygen
would then go and essentially
form a bond, making
this carbon right
over here neutral.
So what is that
going to look like?
And this would happen
faster, so I'm not
going to do this
as in equilibrium.
This could happen like this.
And let me just copy
and paste the bromine,
so I don't have to
redraw the whole thing.
So let me copy, and
let me paste it.
So that's our bromine right
over there, draw it right there.
And actually, let me
erase this little smudge
and make sure it still
has a negative charge.
So negative charge--
it's a bromide anion now.
And now, let me draw
the everything else.
So I have this carbon.
Let me scroll down a little
bit, so I have some space.
Carbon, I have the
carbon in the back-- CH3.
I have the carbon on top-- CH3.
I have the carbon in
front, like that-- CH3.
And now my oxygen, or I should
say, this molecule right over,
the water molecule, has
attached to the carbon.
So these two electrons,
you could say,
they've attacked the carbon.
They now form a bond
with the carbon.
So these are those two
electrons in this covalent bond.
And now, let's draw
the rest of this.
So you have oxygen.
You have these two electrons
over here, these two
valence electrons.
And then you have one hydrogen
and then another hydrogen.
Now, what is going
to be the charge
right over here on the oxygen?
Well, it had a partial
negative charge,
just because it's
more electronegative.
But it just gave essentially
half of a bond, half of a pair.
Or it's now sharing a
pair with this carbon,
so it's equivalent of giving
up one electron's equivalent
of charge.
So you would now say
that this thing right now
has a positive charge.
So you could imagine maybe
another water molecule
comes along.
Let me draw another water
molecule right over here.
We're sitting in
water, so there's
plenty of water molecules.
So another water molecule might
come along and say, OK, well,
this thing right over
here is positive.
But this oxygen is hogging
these bonds a little bit more
than the hydrogens, especially
now that it's become positive.
And so this might give its
pair to a hydrogen proton.
And then this bond
with the hydrogen
will go entirely to the oxygen.
Let me draw that in
a different color.
So this bond right over here
goes entirely to the oxygen.
Electronegativity means if
this is more electronegative
than that, that
if a bond breaks,
that pair is more likely to
go to the more electronegative
molecule, or I should say,
the more electronegative atom.
So what will this look like
when all is said and done?
So let's draw an
arrow like this.
So let me draw my
main molecules.
So I have the carbon.
It bonded to another
carbon right up there.
carbon right over there.
We have our carbon in
front just like that.
We have the bond
with our oxygen.
So we have our bond with
our oxygen right over there.
So that's our oxygen.
We have this bond
with a hydrogen.
We have this pair.
And now, it has
gained this pair.
It has gained this pair
that was with that hydrogen,
so just like this.
This is now neutral.
It went from being
positive-- over here,
it only had half of this bond.
So it's kind of the equivalent
of one electron charge.
Now, it has a whole bond.
So now it has the equivalent.
It literally has both electrons.
So now this thing is neutral.
And now this molecule
right over here
becomes a hydronium cation.
Let me draw that.
So this is water.
So let me see.
So that's the two
hydrogens right over there.
This is that pair
that is on top.
And now it is sharing this
pair with the hydrogen,
essentially with a proton,
so with this hydrogen
right over here.
And now, this will
have a positive charge.
This is a hydronium
cation and maybe
this bumps into
another water molecule
and does the same thing with it.
And it just keeps
going on and on and on.
And of course, we can't forget
our bromide anion friend.
So there's our
bromide anion friend.
We've got a negative
charge right over there.
And so what are we left with?
Well, we are left with-- well,
there's this hydronium cation.
It's a positive charge.
You have this bromide anion.
And now, what is this
molecule now called?
Well, we'll go into more
detail in the future.
But when you have a hydroxyl
group attached to the carbon
backbone, it is an alcohol.
And so our main backbone, once
again, has 1, 2, 3 carbons.
So that tells us prop.
But instead of just saying
propane, it's propanol.
So let's write that down.
This is propan-- and some people
say just propanol, generally.
But if we want to be a
little bit particular,
the hydroxyl group is attached
to the number 2 carbon.
So we would say, propan-2-ol.
And of course, we still
have this blue methyl group.
So we could say 2-methyl--
let me just make this--
2-methylpropan-2-ol is
what we are left with.
Now, let's think
about what we can
name this reaction we just saw.
Well, we've just
substituted a bromo group
with a hydroxyl group.
So I think it's
reasonable to say
that this is going to be
a substitution reaction.
And we substituted with a--
it was a weak nucleophile,
but it was a
nucleophile nonetheless.
So it involved a nucleophile.
But this one, unlike
the Sn2 reaction
in the rate-determining
step-- and this
is the rate-determining step.
This is the slowest
step of the process.
Everything else
will just kind of
start happening once
this thing happens.
This thing kind of
is in equilibrium.
This is the
rate-determining step.
Only one reactant is involved
in the rate-determining step.
In this case, it
was the bromo group.
So you might guess what
we're going to call it.
It's substitution involving a
nucleophile, so nucleophilic
substitution.
You can imagine, this
stands for nucleophilic.
And only one
reactant is involved
in the rate-determining step.
So this right over here, this
whole reaction that we've now
drawn is an Sn1 reaction.
We're now going to
explore one of the most
fundamental reactions
in organic chemistry.
And first, let's
look at what are
the things that
are going to react.
So over here, I have
a hydroxide anion.
It has a negative 1 charge,
and that negative charge
comes from the fact
that oxygen is neutral
if it has six valence electrons.
But this has 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6 plus half
of this bond with hydrogen.
So you could think of that
as another electron or it's
share-- it's got
half of these two,
so that's another
electron, which
gives it a negative 1 charge.
Now, this right over
here, it has one carbon.
I guess, you could
say, in its backbone.
So it's a methane.
And it has a group right over
here consisting of bromine.
So this is bromomethane.
So let's think a
little bit about what
might happen under
the right conditions.
So this hydroxide anion, we've
already gone over the fact
that you can kind of view it as
having an extra electron, which
gives us its negative charge.
Well, if you have a negative
charged anion like this,
it will be attracted
to positive things.
And one example of a
positive thing is a nucleus.
And so in this
reaction, we are going
to refer to this hydroxide
anion as the nucleophile.
Phile literally refers to
things that something likes.
This thing likes--
it's a nucleus lover,
I guess you could say.
And so it might want to share
maybe a pair of electrons
with a nucleus.
Now, over here, I
have this bromo group
in the bromomethane.
And bromine is quite
electronegative.
It is more electronegative
than carbon.
So even in this bond--
we have two electrons
in this bond right
over here-- bromine
is going to hog the electrons
a little bit more than carbon.
And also, electronegativity
says that if this bond were
to break, it's more likely
that this pair, the pair that's
in this bond, is going
to go to the bromine
than it's going to
go to the carbon.
So the way that this reaction
works-- and it's really
kind of happening in
one step, and this
is key to the name
of this reaction,
as we'll see in a second-- is
that this nucleophile right
over here might say,
hey, let me share.
I've got this extra charge.
Let me share some of that
charge with a nucleus,
in this case, the carbon.
Let me draw it like this.
In this case, the
carbon, so it would
share this pair, which
would form a bond.
Carbon would have
half of the pair.
Oxygen would have
So it would share this pair.
It would share this
pair with carbon.
Now, if carbon is now
sharing half of this,
it's essentially
getting an electron.
It doesn't need this electron,
which bromine is already
hogging a little bit.
And so bromine would take
this entire pair back.
Whenever we draw full arrows
like this, just normal arrows
that you're used to
seeing, it's referring
to the action of pairs.
So this whole pair
is going to bromine.
This pair right over
here is now going
to be shared with the carbon.
It's going to form a
bond with the carbon.
So when we do both
of these steps,
after both of these steps,
it would look like this.
Let me draw my
bromine first, which
is now going to become
a bromide anion.
So bromine 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, and now it
gets both of these
electrons from this bond.
So it has both of those
electrons right over there.
Now, this will have
a negative 1 charge.
How do we know that?
Well, bromine is neutral, when
it has seven valence electrons.
This thing now has eight.
So this now has a
negative charge.
Now, once again,
let's think about what
happens to all of this business.
So let me draw my
carbon first, my carbon.
Now, let me draw this
hydrogen that's popping out.
So this hydrogen that's popping
out, let me draw it like that.
So that's the bond,
trying to show
that's popping out of the page.
So that's that hydrogen.
I just made them
different colors,
so we can keep track of
the different hydrogens.
Then the hydrogen that's
going into the page, that's
that one right over there.
And you have this
hydrogen that's going up,
so that hydrogen
right over there.
And now the hydroxide anion
has bonded to this carbon.
Now it will be a hydroxyl group.
So this thing has now bonded.
So let me draw the bond in the
color of these two electrons.
It has now bonded.
So those two electrons
now make up this blur,
this bond right over here.
And now we have our oxygen,
but with those two, these two
right over here, and then
the bond to the hydrogen.
Now, what just happened here?
The oxygen is now neutral.
Why is it neutral?
Well, it has 1, 2, 3, 4.
And then it has
half of this bond,
so you could view
that as an electron
or the equivalent of
an electron charge.
And then it has
half of this bond.
So it has the electron
charge equivalent
of six valence electrons,
which makes oxygen neutral.
And now bromine is negative.
So one way to think about
is that the negative charge
has been transferred to the
bromine in this reaction.
Now, in this reaction,
bromine has left.
And that's why we call
this the leaving group.
We call this right over here the
leaving group of the reaction.
This thing right over
here is the thing
that is going to leave.
That is the leaving group.
Now, the other thing that
you might find interesting,
it looks like kind of
this hydroxide anion--
some people even say--
attacked this bromomethane.
The bromomethane left.
The bromine left, not
bromomethane left.
It attacked the bromomethane.
The bromine left.
So in some ways, you'd
say that there's really
two reactants over here.
You have the hydroxide anion,
and you have the bromide anion.
And this carbon right over
here with the hydrogens,
this was kind of the thing
that just to some degree
facilitated the reaction.
This thing bumped
into it and attached,
and then this thing left.
And so in this context,
we would call the carbon
with a three hydrogens-- we
would call this the substrate.
Now, what should we
call this reaction?
Well one way to think about it
is, we substituted this bromo
group with a hydroxyl group.
So it might make sense to call
this a substitution reaction.
Substitution has occurred.
Now, what did we
substitute with?
Well, we substituted
with a nucleophile.
And how many reactants
were involved
in the rate-determining step?
And I know that might not
make a lot of sense to you,
but this had essentially
one determining step.
This had to want to
bump in the right way.
And this would want to have to
leave right at the same time,
or roughly the
same time, in order
for this reaction to occur.
So this reactant
and this reactant
were involved in
figuring out, well,
how fast is this
reaction going to happen?
And we're going to see future
reactions, where you don't have
both reactants involved in
the rate-determining step.
We'll see only one
reactant involved
in the rate determining step.
But I'll just write this right
over here-- two reactants
in rate determining step.
There's a garbage truck outside.
I think the garbage truck
has left now, safe to resume.
So as we were saying,
there are two reactants
involved in the rate
determining step.
And so the shorthand
for this reaction
is to call it an Sn2 reaction.
It's substitution with
a nucleophile, where
both reactants are involved
in the rate-determining step.